a new trend has been spotted sneaking
into paris fashion shows sneakers seen
in every conceivable combination
sneakers are finally in with the
international fashion crowd they got
very popular for example business woman
they are varying like super elegant or
like just working outfits and they just
take a sneakers because it's comfortable
so I like that the function and the
appearance and the style is like emerged
it's more fun to like a colourful
sneakers and wear something very like
arrogance or like chic sportswear meets
chic at chanel's latest coup to a show
sneakers replace the high heels beneath
the evening gowns fashion journalist
Marcos Abner was at the show which some
called a sensation then the ultimate Eva
Street look after vodka too low when the
ultimate Street look has arrived on the
catwalk something marvelous has happened
has caused our diggers Perseid the start
of video it was also good for orkut sure
which is all too often rather heavy
heavy and here you will reach the high
heel wearers who think to themselves I
could wear this around town or to work
especially when its Yunel CDC team on
unseen order then it's somehow been
blessed and function le son esas of lv k
added in custom made glitter covered
sneakers fashioned from lace tweed or
snakeskin Chanel's models daintily
skipped down the steps the celebrity
guests also enjoy the new freedom of
movement the trainers with the dresses
which I'm sure was a little not to me
good to run in who knew that you could
run in couture Oh Karl Lagerfeld knew
that exclusive old cultural sneakers are
the latest thing with competitor dr as
well creative director of f siemens has
created his own line he's already done
tennis shoes in cooperation with
sportswear maker adidas
relative seizure the citizen but for now
I'm fairly certain that wraps Simmons
collaboration with Adidas for his own
label is what inspired him to think
about sneakers for deals haute couture
pretty odd future by dior the sneaking
after day but women I'm I'll if you've
ever been to adidas in health saga now
lock and seen a [ __ ] in the factory
there and given the subjects and thought
you wouldn't be surprised and I wasn't
to see those odd cacho sneakers on the
door catwalk Gothika zeinab in the
trendsetting Paris boutique Colette
sneakers are among the hottest selling
items these winter days here fashion
conscious shoppers can find original
designs with skull and crossbones comic
or tennis ball motifs alongside the
latest designer models by PF addy and
Valentino this pair can be had for 490
euros the tonto let the 30 years ago
sneakers were still meant for sports the
focus was on helping the wearer achieve
the best possible performance today is
different activity lifestyle the sneaker
has become a lifestyle product for
everyday wear you know and the demands
on it have changed primarily our
customers are looking into how a shoe is
designed and what kind of look it's God
by the mean ones sneakers are also the
latest in footwear for the man about
town and in the recent men's fashion
shows in Paris by Yohji Yamamoto
Valentino and Louie Vito fashion is
indeed getting sporty-er and sportswear
more fashionable this season's models by
Nike have a glittery finish and raised
heels very much in line with this
sneaker wedges as they're called
designed a few years ago by e sabem aha
that's my ID cause the devil atone that
was actually the real revolution when
does the first sneak on he'll show up
and what would a sneak on heels look
like this isabel marant sneakers
probably the most frequently copied
sneaker there is by adidas has just
brought out its vintage Stan Smith model
with wedge heels added its competitor
Nike has revived classics like the air
max and the Blazer and seen them turn
into bestsellers and shoe buyers even
like to customize their models topping
off the trend are several special
editions such as the fur version for the
Chinese year of the horse the pair runs
about one hundred and forty euros
relatively affordable for auto air
models right off the catwalk